[Music]
hi everybody and I started to do some
work on this week's ask mr. wonderful
and went into the database to start
listening to the questions from all
around the world and clearly this is an
extraordinary situation because
everybody is concerned about the
pandemic of the krona virus how it's
affecting the families how it's
affecting their businesses how it
affects them how to fix their jobs so
I've got hundreds of questions on this
here's what I've decided to do rather
than try and just pick one or two or
three or four even I've kind of got the
themes of all these hundreds of
questions and I've tried to pick one in
each genre and we're gonna talk about it
but let me tell you what I want to do
for this week because I think this is
really important I'm sitting isolated
now in Miami I've decided to stay here
and ride this out in in our home here
we have kids in different cities and my
wife has traveled to be close to them
and so we're trying to keep our family
together and you know everybody's trying
to figure this out on their own way and
clearly health is paramount and
listening to the advice from doctors and
the government and everything else about
social distancing but basically I'm
looking out at the ocean right now at an
extraordinary scene that I've never seen
in my whole life we're in the middle of
March break this is a time when there
are hundreds of thousands of people on
the beaches of Miami and there isn't a
single person even walking on the beach
[Applause]
it's very eerie just to see it and and I
mean nobody and that's because the
police have told everybody that you
cannot go on the beach and they've made
sure you don't have access to it anymore
and people are concerned obviously about
the corona virus but it's kind of a
unique situation
I've decided here to stay and work here
you can see it's a mess I'm I'm I'm
dealing with all of my companies and my
investments I spent a lot of time
speaking to them every day I'm pretty
well locked in here I go out you know
once a week to go get some groceries and
I take an electric bike to do it I don't
want to get in the car you know I should
show you this I mean unlike everybody
else trying to figure out you know do I
wear a mask I've got one you know it's
just a strange different way to live and
yeah I've been I've been using it I and
gloves and everything else but we're all
in this together
so I thought I'd spend this week talking
about it and I and I've decided to do
something else as well um I've asked a
couple of doctors to come on the show
this week I'm going to bring them in by
zoom and I want you to hear what they've
told me and I've got dr. Sahlman from
Boston who is a very good pragmatic
doctor about how to live within the
context of the fear of catching this
virus and how you should conduct your
life around it and near it and what you
do with family and how you travel but
I've also brought a very special guest
dr. David Kennedy I'm going to be
talking to him and you're gonna hear
what he has to say he was the doctor the
respiratory specialist at Ground Zero
for SARS he's lived through this and
he's now doing exactly the same thing
with the corona virus he's in the
hospital he's dealing with it he
understands the nature of pandemic like
this and he has some very interesting
observations about this particular virus
and what we should and what we can learn
from him is gonna be very interesting so
those are those are my two guests on
this show we're to get to them later
but I'd like to get to answer some of
these questions and and I think these
will be relevant to everybody and so
listen to this and let's talk about it
my fiesta my fiance and I got laid up
from a start-up a week before the
outbreak got really bad no one's hiring
during this difficult time and soon many
people will be in the same boat we
worked in digital marketing growing
economy obviously this is this is a time
when hiring for marketers is going to
stop altogether it's a question is this
a time when hiring for market is going
to stop altogether and it's a great
question and the others no it's not you
know companies now have to shift I've
talked to almost all of my portfolio
they're not all doing great because some
of them are involved in retail some of
they're involved in products and
services that have a lot to do with
people getting together but others their
businesses are booming because they sell
products and services for home offices
for example or individual workout gyms
and so everybody has different problems
but they're all trying to connect
directly with their customers and
they're trying to get strategies where
they can take their old retail
businesses and bring them online and
during this period which we don't know
how long it's going to last they're
gonna try and sell direct and to do that
they need help and I've certainly
believe that digital marketers that have
great skill sets that know how to work
with the different platforms are going
to be very very valuable they're just
gonna have to work like I am from home
communicating directly with customers
online I've been doing zoom meetings
five six seven eight a day with as many
as a hundred people online it's it's an
eerie new way to do business but it's
incredibly efficient but it's the same
tool that you would be using as a
marketer to help your clients and
understanding the way the algorithms are
shifting on all these platforms as
things change is really important so no
I don't think you have to lose your job
or be completely unemployed you have to
find a new way to engage your customers
and reach out to them which by the way
even big companies are doing now I don't
care what business you're in
there's nobody walking on the streets
there's nobody going to restaurants all
of those companies are trying to change
their strategies to survive and stay
alive but you know I keep I can't help
saying it over and over again you got it
you got to figure out some way over the
next three to four months maybe we don't
know how long it's going to be to keep
the DNA of your business intact here's
another question working alone without
coworkers or bosses around doesn't give
me a sense of teamwork yeah I get this
one no chattering break to boost team
morale and there's no opportunity to
build rapport with clients for upcoming
work how do you stay motivated working
from your home when you thrive in a
social environment well I totally get
that question I feel totally isolated
here I mean I don't even see any people
walking anywhere what's keeping me
connected is social media it's speaking
and talking to people in meetings I've
probably done six of them today using
Facebook I'm using LinkedIn I'm using
Twitter I'm communicating to my base
companies and social media contacts on
pretty well Instagram everything for
every platform and in and that sense of
being part of a community even without
having that the physical contact is
something that gives me some relief and
it should be the same for you now when
you need to talk to a human being I'll
tell you what I'm doing in my family I'm
organizing a family zoom every night
just to check up on everybody how's
everybody doing how's it going it's kind
of a routine we do it at 7 o'clock and
it really helps me feel that we're still
together even though were thousands of
miles apart nobody can move I've got my
father sitting in Switzerland you can't
get in or out of there
my daughter's in New York my wife is
somewhere else right now in transit
we'll all get together tonight my son's
also you know working his engineering
lab and he's not moving anywhere right
now so this is going to be an
extraordinary time and and I think you
can rely whether you use you know
there's so many different tools you can
Skype the one I am falling in love with
and I you know I am a shareholder of the
company but that's just part of my one
of my ETFs zoom is this come out of
nowhere as a two
because I think they've done a really
good job in making that platform really
easy to use and indeed when I invite
these doctors to come on the show later
I'm going to zoom them and you're gonna
see them as I record those interactions
and I think we're gonna get a lot of
good information on that but whichever
one you want to choose there you are
you're communicating with a live person
and it just feels better but I got to
admit sitting here feels pretty weird
it's I've never actually sad I guess the
best way to the best analogy is you've
got to pick your prison you have to
decide where you're gonna put yourself
down for I don't know a month six weeks
who knows pick your prison surround
yourself with whatever it is that you're
gonna need to keep your sanity get a
good book even go back to that I mean my
routine is I've got a lot of laptops
here a lot of Technology a broadcast
camera
I'm just keeping myself busy all day
long and connecting with my companies
and my entrepreneurs and my team in my
own business and it's it's challenging
though I'm you know I'm not gonna make
light of it you know yeah I'm doing my
own shopping and I'm cooking all my own
meals
I'm not even ordering in takeout but
like I want to I want to lose some
weight actually I'm cooking really lean
and mean and a lot of people don't know
this I'm a pretty good cook I'm kidding
chops back a chef wonderful I got to
tell you some of my more complicated
dishes I'm even gonna make creme flambe
and escargot just to keep myself busy
set the table put a candle out and they
spot a wine dinner for one me okay
here's another one I'm a psychiatrist
and many of my patients asked me how to
reduce their anxiety around the market
and the market crash it seems that the
anxiety driven by buyers is just as bad
as the economic crash itself thoughts or
recommendations this is a great question
you know there's a whole generation of
investors that have never seen a decline
like this before
I've been this through this multiple
times and here's what I've learned and
listen I'm just giving you my advice I'm
not telling you how to invest but here's
what I've learned the market has had an
extraordinary sell-off over 30% in the
major indexes in a really short period
of time and we've actually self declared
a recession even though we know the
numbers to justify it yet I'm not saying
it won't come but it's the first time in
my life I've ever seen it declared or a
recession before the numbers even
justified it
that's how pessimistic we are and that
emotion has got a lot of people selling
stocks now if you're lucky and you've
been holding back a little cash I'm not
saying everybody has done this you're
putting it back to work in the market
but you can't pick the bottom you just
can't if you have a hundred dollars put
ten dollars to work every second day or
spread it out a little bit and you'll
get some bad days and some good days but
here's the piece of advice I want to
tell you in a recovery after this
whenever it happens there's going to be
extraordinary days when huge returns are
made in a few hours 5 6 7 8 9 percent
and if you're not invested at that time
you will completely miss out and very
often in violent downturns they're met
later with violent up swings where the
majority of returns in a whole year come
in a few days
I'm not kidding in a few days and if
you're not invested in that period you
will not get those returns and so you
got to kind of ride it out it hurts it's
painful it's emotionally stressful but
that is the nature and the volatility of
markets we've gotten so docile in the
last few years that markets only going
one way up well we're back in reality
volatility that is the derivative of
capitalism there's still no better
system we'll get through this together
we'll be building businesses and I can
tell you one thing about
entrepreneurship having lived with
entrepreneurs my whole life and been one
myself right now somewhere somebody is
solving a problem that has been created
by this horrific virus and the way it's
changed our lives and that business in a
few years we'll be a giant
what it is but that's the nature of
entrepreneurs they're always trying to
solve problems with services and
products that they dream up to help
people and that's where values created
and it's gonna happen again I have total
faith in entrepreneurship in America
it's going to happen over and over again
all around the world - there's
entrepreneurs and every country affected
by this working hard to solve problems
for help fellow human beings and that's
what I love about entrepreneurship ok
let's get back to the questions Wow I'm
from Arizona and my family and I own a
restaurant we had to send all our
workers home and limit ourselves to just
take out business what approach should
we take how should we manage the money
we have at the time which is right now
you know I've got lots of companies in
this situation let me tell you what I'm
advising them and we've had multiple
meetings together in a time like this
let's just take a restaurant in a time
like this everybody that services that
restaurant understands what's going on
that includes the landlord that includes
the staff that includes the food
suppliers that includes the cleaners
it's everybody there all together making
that business work and they all benefit
from when it's working so now that we're
in a period of stress it's time to share
the pain so what I've asked my
restaurant tours to do is to say look go
to the landlord let's start there which
is often one of the biggest costs and
say I've been a great tenant for years
you know if you've been a great tenant
for years you got to declare it now and
I'm gonna need some help I don't have
anybody coming into my restaurant
anymore
now you don't tell your your landlord
you're not gonna pay them ever you ask
for some leeway for some time and for
example say to them look would you give
me the next two months could I defer
rent you're not asking them that you're
to never pay them you're asking them to
defer rent just to take the pressure off
you to keep the DNA of your business
going to keep everything intact for when
it comes back and I like to know my
entrepreneurs today let's deal in the
context of 90
three months three months we don't know
what's gonna happen but we may see the
other end of this mess in three months
or at least the beginning of some kind
of normalcy in China right now the
number of cases are reducing quickly
maybe we got our act together here too
hopefully we will generally speaking
we're gonna move quickly on this one the
government resources are pouring into it
but the idea for the entrepreneur in
this case this restaurant tour is deal
in terms of 90 days then go to your
suppliers and say look can I stretch the
payment for just 60 of those 90 days
help me with my business you're gonna be
amazed how many people say yeah I can
help you not everybody's going to but
some well then you go to your employees
and say look I only have two options I
have to either have to lay you off which
I don't want to do because I want to
keep you in my world to bring you back
when things normalize or stagger shifts
where you work one day and you don't
another on the takeout business if there
is a takeout business or I'll cut your
salary for doing that for this period if
I can just to keep you going
just to keep you sustained and that's
how you work together you make it
everybody's challenge because it's
everybody's benefit when the business
stays together and in talking with my
companies over the last 10 days on this
about 60% of them are getting relief
this way they really are the people they
work with want to help them that's the
nature of entrepreneurship that's the
nature of working together that's the
nature of running a business it's going
to be tough there's no question about it
but you're going to find people want to
help I wish you good luck on that one
all right let's go and talk to some
doctors about this let's get some advice
let's start with dr. Martin Solomon I've
known this man for decades I found him
to be a fantastic pragmatic doctor he's
my doctor I've asked him a lot of
questions I want to hear what you has to
he has to say you should hear what he
thinks this is really interesting and
he's taken some of the fear out of my
family he's he's given us great advice
to think about how to deal with what's
out there I've also got on the line dr.
David Kennedy now he's really
interesting because he was part of the
Ground Zero team
the SARS epidemic remember that broke
out in China and he can draw the analogy
between what happened there and what's
happening now and he's also involved in
helping patients with this pandemic
right now he's a respiratory expert we
want to hear from him we want to hear
from both of them look there's so much
misinformation out there and that's why
everybody's at freak out factor six what
we need are facts let's get to the
doctors so let's just start with how
would I know I have this virus this
corona virus how how would how would I
know if many people it doesn't manifest
itself it how would I know
know so the context of that question is
you know is this something I need to
worry about so here's the basic element
to it most people who have corona virus
I'm not going to either have any
symptoms or have minimal symptoms as if
they have a simple respiratory illness
the people who need to worry will know
that they're sick so for example today
one of my family members called to say
got a fever to a hundred and one aching
all over I have a terrible headache
minor cough what do you think's going on
the primary symptom or the Universal
symptom and the one that typically on
says first and as present and
ninety-eight percent of patients is
fever so you're going to get a fever and
you're gonna feel unwell and you're
gonna probably almost certainly develop
a cough so cough and fever are the
hallmark symptoms and Kevon keep in mind
this is not an upper respiratory tract
disease so you don't have a lot and then
although it can happen things like
running noses sore throats or not the
commonest presentation of this disease
although it can happen most of the time
it's a lower respiratory tract condition
so cough particularly dry cough and
fever of the Communists presentations
followed by shortness of breath or
difficulty breathing I said you've got
corona virus but hopefully he's young
and healthy and so there's no need to
test for two reasons one is because we
can't get the tests
unless you meet criteria and you have to
be in real respiratory distress now
because there's such a shortage of tests
and the other reason not to test is most
people will just get better so even
though we'd like to know where it is and
how many cases there are you don't need
to really be terribly worried with those
symptoms how old was this person you're
talking about 48 so what is the real age
that you should start to sweat bullets
if you get a fever 101 and you know
something's wrong well you know fever
and small children is always a concern
very small children infants and children
under the age of 1 don't dissipate fever
as well as adults do so any fever and
that age group is bad
but in terms of the risk of coronavirus
it's a concern with everybody until
about two weeks ago we all felt pretty
comfortable that children weren't
getting sick with this but now they are
and so the disease somehow is either
changing in our country or the
susceptibility is different but anybody
who develops fever and feels like
they've been hit by a truck they've got
most likely coronavirus as the regular
flu season is starting to weigh no no
doubt that SARS was a disease that had a
bad or a higher fatality rate but wasn't
nearly as contagious as this one is this
particular virus is even more contagious
than influenza so influenza probably two
to three times more contagious so what
is it about it I don't think we've
worked that out yet there are certain
receptors on the external surface of the
virus that bind to human cells there's
something different with this corona
virus and the other ones but the exact
mechanism or the differences that cause
it to be more contagious I don't think
are yet established so if I get the Rea
let's say I'm 48 and 50 whatever I get
hit I got a fever
I've got Corona I'm not even getting
tested how long am I going to be sick
for and I'm assuming I got a cell
isolate even if I'm
all with other people I gotta be in a
bedroom by myself or something right
right so the answer to that is divided
and all of these things have different
approaches so if you have fever and body
aches and you feel like you get
coronavirus but it doesn't get any worse
than that you're probably going to be
better in five or six days but you have
to continue to isolate for at least 14
days because it takes that long for the
acute illness to stop now there are
studies coming out of China and Italy
and I have this from people are doing
the major research on the vaccines that
you continue to shed virus for as much
as four to five weeks afterwards so
that's a little scary I'm not sure what
to do with that information where to
five weeks that that's viable virus that
could infect somebody else yes yes and
we don't know who that is that's a big
problem it's a very big problem so I
could feel great I told her my fever is
gone I'm feeling good again you've
isolated for 14 days and you go outside
you could theoretically still pass it
along it's interesting because I
remember when SARS was going on I had
very vigorous discussions with my
colleagues about the probability of
occurring and some of them particularly
one gentleman who was very famous in the
SARS epidemic named Don lo Don reassured
me shortly after SARS was over that it
would never come back and the reason he
gave was that there was no animal or
human host for the virus and he was
actually quite correct so a virus needs
a host to sustain it and to pass it on
and make it transmissible SARS had no
human or animal host this particular
coronavirus is still too early to tell
at this point we don't know if it's
going to recur we don't know if there is
a sustainable human host that is going
to maintain itself so the there is a
possibility once we get enough tests of
doing follow-along
tests so if you're still shedding virus
and
you don't go out but we're not there yet
their note I'm having a terrible time
getting people tested right now so we're
america here and we can't get enough
tests what happened
yeah we're a third-world country right
now when it comes to coronavirus we just
didn't get ready with enough tests for
this well people just ignored the
opportunity you know it's I don't want
to get too political but getting rid of
the pandemic office in the White House
was a huge mistake pretending that this
was just a cold for a month was a
mistake and we lost a lot of time we
could have been ready for this okay
you've been a medical professional as
long as I've known you
what's your take until we're out of this
mess because I'm sitting here alone
sequestered in my Miami apartment in the
surreal world we're looking at the beach
with not a single person on it the town
is a ghost town it's strange how long we
in this for this is very different
because obviously it's a pandemic rather
than an epidemic so pandemic implying
that's affecting pretty much most if not
all countries across the world well we
just got word in in Boston that we very
likely will get a seclusion order in the
next 48 hours I think that if the
country really walks down for two or
three weeks we can flatten this out and
get out of it the same way the Chinese
did but I don't see it happening what
happened in Florida with Spring Break in
with leaving the restaurants open
letting this I think it just let the cat
out of the bag I think we're in this for
the long haul I would be surprised it's
all summer and what's a long haul yeah I
would be surprised if we're out of this
bite you so what would say that date
again June June
yeah and that's really what that's
producing hitting here alone till June
okay so let me ask some practical
questions I gotta eat so I don't go to
restaurants I go to the Fresh Market I
have some instruments here I have a mass
I have
our gloves should I be wearing this
stuff when I go out shopping you don't
need to wear the mask you should wear
the rubber gloves if you're going to be
in close proximity to people on the
chance that somebody might be coughing
around you you couldn't wear the mask
but as a general rule the mask is not
going to protect you when you're outside
better thing to do is actually have food
delivered to you and then to open the
food the boxes take the food out wash
your hands and then handle the food
should I wash the food do I have to
somehow no no no no there's no evidence
that is transmissible through food okay
so but the virus itself sitting on a
surface on the box that gets filtered to
me because these are kind of the
pragmatic issues people are freaking out
about I've got all these questions if
people say because it's it the delivery
guy delivers my food takeout food or
fresh frozen is it on the box yes well
it could be so you open the box with
gloves you throw out the packaging or
dispose of it someplace and then you
take the gloves off you wash your hands
and then you retrieve the food I don't
and so I don't have to prepare my food I
can eat a salad I can eat fresh salad no
problem
most likely yeah I mean it does not
appear to be passing through the food
chain you know looking back at this a
year from now we may think differently
about it but at the moment it's all
being passed person-to-person contact
okay I've got at least a hundred
questions about regimens for bolstering
my immune system from zinc to I be with
you I'll give you one answer forget all
that other stuff so the only thing
that's ever been shown to reliably
shorten and diminish the intensity of
viral illnesses is vitamin C and that's
that's been around a long time it's not
it you can't prevent colds but you can
significantly suppress them and I've
been taking a thousand milligrams a day
of vitamin C now for all
two weeks I've advised everybody who
asks me that that's what they should do
and I think the evidence for that is
strong all the other stuff sync and all
kinds of supplements that there's just
no scientific evidence it doesn't mean
you can't take them but there's no
science fine but vitamin C may help to
mitigate okay tons of questions about
family members younger family members
coming back to visit parents and
grandparents that have coming that they
kicked out of colleges now pretty well
Harvard in your town everywhere but he's
kicked out they're all coming home
alright here's a question saying should
I test my 23 year old son before I let
him in the door no but it would be
reasonable to sequester them for two
weeks in the house just don't be near
them that would be a reasonable thing to
do not crazy or you could take your
chance if you can't test them the
testing is crazy
can't get the test but that that is
happening all over America there's
hundreds of students coming home so this
could in effect be another way it gets
passed especially the students who did
crazy stuff like going to spring break
in Florida you're going to spread it all
over the country yeah that's a problem
they've shut the beaches down now but it
was for about a ways too late going back
to the one thing I know people are going
to freak out about what you said was and
I want to make sure we understand this
if I get it and I survive it and I'm
feeling better I could be shedding virus
for up to three weeks that's scary but
can I get it again or like Donna yes so
it's unclear yet people have immunity
the people who are making a vaccine so
I've spoken to are just not certain
about that yet you know there are a lot
of people who get exposed to viruses and
don't get immunity for example shingles
you can get shingles and then get
shingles again now coronavirus is a
different kind of virus so we don't
know the answer to that we would like to
think that you can't get it again
but I don't think we know that yet it's
too early in this process to know the
other part of it is that this is just a
more aggressive virus but not all
viruses are the same
this virus passes more easily and it's
it's effects are very less
the incidence of toxicity of severe
illness of death is higher than most of
those other illnesses is do you know
what the death rate is now in the
general population I mean people dying
more people have still died from the
regular flu in the last two years right
right but if you look at the curve of
incidence knowing what's happening the
spread of the disease this is going to
far surpass influenza within it within
another week we'll be way past approval
odds okay Martin finally is there
anything you would like to say to all
the people are gonna see this that could
be a little more optimistic anything and
obviously no no no if everybody
recognizes that we're all part of this
and everybody recognizes the importance
of isolation of preventing contact with
others in order to get this under
control we can stop this illness this is
not going to be stopped with a vaccine
it's not going to be stopped with a
miracle medicine because there's nothing
going to be available for a long time
but we can stop this with isolation it
works and if anybody's not sure I'm sure
you've seen the graphs look at the
graphs of incidents of illness and death
from the flu illness that struck the
United States a hundred and fifty years
ago and the difference between st. Louis
and Philadelphia it looks like the
mitigation non mitigation curves and
everybody is working at these days after
trying to accomplish with the virus the
incidence of death and disease in
Philadelphia where they had a fare and
they didn't restrict it all goes up to a
point very high death rate and then
gradually trails
st. Louis which immediately told
everybody to stay home stopped all
social connections for a period of a
couple of weeks as a flat curve same
illness two separate American
communities state and a half apart you
think I mean if everybody sequester's
and there's no more person-to-person
transmission theoretically like this
totally theoretically this could be over
two to three weeks well that would be
great okay
my polity as we both know is that's not
going to happen there's going to be
transmission hopefully the rate goes
down so that's why it's gonna I think
that's why it's going to drag on into
the summer is the summer help kill the
saw I think I think on surfaces that
there's probably some truth to it I mean
I don't think viruses viruses love cold
so if you were to take a virus and you
were to say I want to keep this around
for a hundred years because I want to
study it down the road and you're the
CDC and you want to just sort of keep
your you're a bola or you're kovat or
whatever you know so for research
purposes you you freeze it and viruses
love that they love cold so they'll
survive forever so my theory of being in
a really hot place where all the
surfaces during the day or you know
they're up at 90 degrees I could you
know if I chair out on the beach is
Friday I'd like to think that a virus
there's a hell of a tough time with that
in a way it probably does it's going to
survive but it's going to survive a lot
shorter period of time but the problem
Kevin is most of the transmission is
probably not at the beach it's at the
coffee shop it's at the party it's at
the workplace it's at the social
gatherings of whatever is tight whether
it's church or otherwise it's people are
going to get it when the temperature not
just is 90 degrees but you know when
you're when you're at Starbucks and
you're picking up your coffee cup and
the guy happened to pass it on to you
you know it's 70 degrees there you know
it's an air-conditioned environment I
have one last final question and I was
saying and asked the doctor what his
daily protocol is and how he interacts
with his patients and then goes home
what is he doing about well it's it's
changing every day it's getting more and
more strength
strict and and limited so instead of
getting up in the morning and going to
the hospital to make rounds which I
can't do now because I'm restricted I'm
not allowed to go into the hospital I
get up in the morning I do my workout
and I sit down on my computer I answer
all the mail that needs to be done and
now I'm seeing patients on my computer
either virtually or using telehealth
visits to communicate with them and try
and deal with things and then we have a
procedure for screening people as to
whether or not they need to go in to get
screened or treated and then we have
locations set up for people with non
respiratory problems where patients can
be seen so if somebody thinks they're in
your office if somebody thinks they have
have the virus they don't come in to
your office t no nobody we screen
everybody out of the office there's it's
actually almost nobody in the office now
mostly its handling phone calls and
ordering tests and doing paperwork but
if somebody calls and they have an on
corona symptom and people still get sick
so somebody calls for chest pain or
abdominal pain but we have we have it
set up so people can get care where they
need together thank you so much for your
time today I think a lot of people to
listen to this you know as you can
imagine the amount of angst out there is
never been higher it's it's amazing
we're going through it ourselves all of
us everybody feels that anxiety and the
other part of it is I think it's
important to keep a routine going you
know there's a lot of jokes going around
on the Internet this is me before
Korona and this is me after thin fat
keep up a routine you need to exercise
if you're allowed to go out so I didn't
get fresh air or walk you know try to
maintain a routine for yourself because
isolation can be very destructive the
emotional impact is huge and remember
all of us are upset and depressed about
anybody who's not obsessed or depressed
about this isn't paying attention
and so it's okay to feel that way that
was great information from both of them
both kena wotty and Solomon's said one
thing that I heard and I hope you did
too do not mess with this virus it is
very very contagious so don't go out if
you're sequestering yourself with your
family or by yourself do not have the
temptation after a while to get out
there I was invited to a dinner party
for example tonight everybody said don't
worry about it nobody's sick how about
no no Nanette I'm not doing that how do
they know they're not infected there's a
14-day quarantine period
I'm not messing around with this thing
and either should you you've got to have
the discipline you heard of a Solomon
you heard it from Kenna Wadi you've got
to make sure that you can stay focused
on the objective which is basically
don't catch this thing so don't go out
if you don't have to don't mingle with
people you don't know stay close to home
and let's ride this thing out together
it's been a crazy week stay safe
I'll see you soon